Here's a pretty flower that knits
quickly without hand manipulation.
It's worked in multiples of 10,
but you can vary the multiple and change
the finished size of the flower
by changing the number of stitches.
I cast on 100 stitches
with waste yarn and ravel cord.
This gives you somewhere to hang the cast
on comb and weights,
making knitting easier.
The cast on edge will be the edges
of the flower, so use contrasting
yarn or a decorative cast on.
For this flower, I just e wrapped
with two strands of the dark color.
For this flower, I used a picot cast on.
Once your cast on is complete,
put all the needles into hold position
and set your carriage to hold.
Put 10 needles next to the carriage
into working position.
Thread up your main color
Yarn and knit two rows.
There's no need to wrap anything.
Now put 10 more needles into working
position and knit another two rows.
Continue knitting this way,
adding needles into work every other row.
Can you see the long skinny
triangle taking shape?
When you finish the last section,
make sure your carriage is on the right.
Break the yarn, leaving a tail.
Using a double eyed needle,
remove all the stitches to the tail.
I like to keep the waste yarn
on temporarily and block the piece.
Now pull up the tail of yarn and gather
up the piece forming the flower shape.
Secure the ends with
the tails of the yarn.
You can stitch the flower directly
to a garment or attach it
to a pin for easy removal.
These little accessories can add just
the right touch to your knitting.